here is uh governor ron desantis
responding to a little bit of charlie
chris nonsense on tucker carlson so i
want to ask you quickly about your race
we learned the other day on last tuesday
that charlie crist who beat the zany
weed lady he was running against is
going to be your opponent and christ a
former republican came out today with a
message to your supporters which i want
our viewers to see here it is
those who support the governor should
stay with them and vote for him and i
don't want your vote
if you have that hate in your heart keep
it there
i want the vote of the people of florida
who care about our state
he doesn't want your vote you're morally
beneath him i've never seen a politician
say that
this is his fifth decade running for
office he's a chameleon typical career
politician but you know tucker people
support me because i kept the state open
and protected their jobs charlie crist
wanted it locked down so that's not hate
in their heart they're just appreciative
that they had a governor who was
standing up for them parents around the
state support me because we made sure
schools were open and we're working to
make sure they get education not
indoctrination that's not hate in their
heart they're just appreciative that
they have a governor that's fighting for
them it's so it's kind of weird to see
charlie crist look down his nose at
voters is there anyone in the state who
is more morally suspect than charlie
crist who's registered to vote that
you're aware of
i'll tell you what uh i would take uh
yeah i i don't think you can i think he
is not one to be cast in stones and how
temptable it is when he says he claims
that he wants to unify florida he says
he wants a florida for all and then you
condemn a majority of the people in the
state of florida give me a break and the
thing about what i've done is you know
we've done issues that people across the
spectrum have been able to agree with
and that's really what it's all about
it's not hating the other side it's
trying to have policies that a majority
can agree with
if you don't support me you're a hater
that doesn't work i hope it doesn't
isn't that interesting and that tactic
telling the truth hey this is what i am
this is who i am this is what i stand
for this is what i've done as opposed to
those people who don't like me they have
hate in their hearts i have been around
an awful lot of desantis supporters and
a lot of the desantis team i've met a
whole bunch of really nice people some i
have some political disagreements with i
suppose
but if that that's one message there's a
clear message of honesty and reality and
then there's just this sort of fake
crazy message but this crazy message is
spreading everywhere with the democrats
and this is what i need
uh i would say
my good democrat friends or any of you
who are still on the fence about what is
happening here where are the say because
i think most of you watching this you
probably you probably think of yourself
as somewhat conservative but but
centrist in a lot of ways the way that
we all sort of were in the 90s something
like that
and
we that is in stark contrast to what the
democrats of today have become
have become whether you're talking about
that crazy biden speech whether you're
talking about christ saying that half
the people in florida have hatred in
their hearts